H A EV YESTERDAY.N WHO SOLCRETSD
UNKNOWN SECOND GRAND JURY IN THF
D ASACT,
ALSO UNCLEHEN HE
SPECIACH LINE OF I THE
R JANUARY 6th OR
IS HERE.ND KAITLAN COLLINS
WHAT HAVE YOU D?
>> A LOT OQUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
ESPECIAL WO THE EA
, THAT'S -- OR THE MARK
WE KNEW HE WAS GOING T TO
TEE THEY SUBPOENAED
HIM, THE TRUMP TEAM TRIED TO
FIGHT ING UTE
PRIVILEGE.
AT, SO WE KNEW IT
W WHEN, NOW WE
S IGH
THESE IN
THAT I.
>> AND WAS WITH TH
JA  WITH UGHOUT THE
6th
WAS ONCE HIS REPRESENTIV
THE NATIONAL AHIS AT THE
INSTWAS ON PL TRUMP HAD
SECRETARY OF
W THERE'S
ATEC OF TRUMP
TALKING ABOUHAVING THEM --
>>E WENT DOWN TO GEORGIASOORGIA
THAT WE AC
SPIAWAE
WAS WRITINGK,GHOST WRITING AND
BIOGRAPHERS RECORDED
CONVERSATION.
>> IN THE --T ISAND
ARE GOING BEFORE THE GRANDY S T
WAGTDN'T SACTIVITY SINCE MAYND
WEW THE'E CONVN
WITNESSES ARFORE THEM WHEN IT CB
EXACTLY THND GRA J
T TH THAT,
WHETHER OR NOT CHARGES, IFE BRO
BROUGHT IN MIAMIIN
WASHINGTON, WHICH WOULD MAKE A
ENCE, WHAT W
WITNESS HAS GONE BOR
GRAND JU,  WITNESSESW AND SO
IT'S CERTAINLY CONTINUING TO
PROGRESS.
>>AT I
THEY'RE STILL HAVING WITNESSESSY
N THE LAST SEVERAL S.
NOT CLEAR WHEN EXACTLYEY WITNESS
TOMORROW, WE'RE TOLD.
FO FEDERAL PROSECUTOIED RVING A.
ELIE, WHAT DO YOU MA O
>> COULD BE CO
IT COULD BE A CONVENIENCE TH
COURTESY TO WITNESSES RE ARE WIG
OR UNABLE TO COME UPO IS TAKE T
YOU CAN JUST REAEIR
F THE CASE  THE GRAND JURY IN
THAT'SNL I
EXAMPLE, IFHE
LOOKING AT CRGSOMEONE WHO WORKEA
THAT PERSON WOULCONNECTION TO W
THEN OPTN C, T BIGCOULD BE THEYP
IN FTHER THA
WAIND.C. ANDROHAVE A LOT OF DIS
ABOUT --
>> YOU G0 CHOOSEHAL G TO
SEE HOW THE CRIMEION OF THESO
FLORIDNTE
G CRIME AN
OBSTE.HE OTHER O.
THE ARMELD B TOCUMENTS FRO, GHT?
THOUSC
OF THE CRIME BUT THE ENT TO THA,
BUT IF THE FAI
-A-LAGO BEFORE ST
PRESIDENCY AND THE ILLEGALHEOW
SEF WHOLE CRIM
AND YO IT IN.  I
AE QUESTION, A BIG
IT'S THE KEEPING OF THDOCUMENTS
THHE WHO I HAVAB,
MP BAS GONE AND D, WE KNOW, D TH
MOVING BOXES, IS
TESTIMONY AND THEN
>> JOHN DEANS TOUGH
TO OVERSTATEMEADOWS'
IM
HOUSE AND OSENESS TORY 6.
DE A GRAND JUR
D KNOW WHEN THIS WAS ORKNOW, O.
A BI BECAUSE HE
REMARKABLY I
WEONERN,HE HASL LIAB
EXPOSURE FROAN HISTIES ATHE P O
ATN I DO KNOW HE HTH
BETTER ATTORNEYS IN THE PICTUREE
DEPART OE INCLUDINTY
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO COU
E PROCESS
POSSIBLY GET THROUGH WITS  A
STORYILL.BUT A VERY IMPORTANT.O
HOW THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S TEAM
STANDOING?
>> MY SENSE FROM
SOMETH D TK TO HIM
THAT MUCH D  C TRUMP THIT S
LEAM IS WORRIED BEE IOUSLY CENT
HNG TO  THESE INVESTITIAND MAYY
LAST TIMWAHESPEAKING THI
EIO THERE'S NOT -- WHI
SPEAHETIONS SOAIR THEM
L,WE WOULDN'T KNOW BIT, WHENOU
WE KNOW AB>> WE WOULD CEAINLY K
TN CASE THAT I
HAS GUARANTEED FULL D TRUTHFUL
CHOOSE MARK AD KAITLAN
SAID HE' IN
RD AND.
HE IS BY TRUMP SIDE AT KEYMOMENA
JANUARY 6th.HENEBERS ONGRESS
FAEXIM
PRING.VEET
HE'S T KT
WITH
FIFTH?ONY COBE INVALUABLE. ST PD
THE, TESTIFY
AND HOPE FOR THE BE VE RISKY PO.
MO
R  HE'S GOING TO
TAKE THE FIFTH AND TDO AS A
Y, WE'RE NO
USG WE CAN'T PCU
NOYOOU T
S AT THIS POINTHAT THEY
ACTUALLY WILL SEEK AN INDICTMEH.
WHAT I'M IS, IS WHER HIM AL IN E
.
THAT'SOR
LAW AND N TROUBLE WI
TAKE A DEAL IFE S OFFEREONE.
DEAN, APPRECIATE IT,
ELIE HONIGKAITLAN WILL BBA TOP
WITH ME.
JOINING US IS FORMER ILLINOIS BL
FORMANUARY 6th SELECT  RESSMAN,A
EA
RY. MEAN, IT'S
POSSIBILITIES.
I'M AS CONFUSED AS ANYONE.
I THINK IT'S QUITEE THAT
RELATED TO JANUARY 6th OWHATEV.
THEY'RE RESTING,E AN
THEY HAVEN'T METY
FLORIDA IN BECAUSE
O THE SIXT TO GIVE
OWN AREATTED DOWN
THERE,NE
HOPE SOMETHING THAT IT'SE A RES.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIT.
BUT, YEAH, I
CONFUSING TO IT IS T
AN
>> YOU WERE ON
COMMITTEE.
MEADOWS.R THOUGHTS ON MARK
TESTIFIED TO A GRAY.NOSAID OR I
OR JANUA 6BEEN.
HUGE AND I HEARD ELIE YI
EARLIER ABOUT, YOU KT
MESSAGES EING
HIS ANBEWE NOTN THE FIRSMEAD
MESSAGES ON THE JANU6th
COMMITTEE, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
MUCH HARDER FOGE THE
ANSWERS THAT W
TONITIAL
TRANUI
COOPERATING WITH THE COMMIBUT  W
FONED SAW   MEMBE O
TORSHAD USTHEN TO BE ABL CONNEC.
HE WAS RTHE ALL-STAR ON
EVIDENCE PROVIDED.
SO NOEINA D JURY AND IS HETUT
COMPARISON.
>>S LOUNGING HERE WHILE
YOKI
HE W.
DEDEA OF AHER PRT.
WHAT WOULD THAIL? THERE'S A COU
OU
THAT COUA GUILTY
EAEXS
AND HOPG
REDUD .
THAT'S YOUR STAN COOPERATOR
MECRIME.MARK
THE OTTH
BEFORE, THEIMMUNIEAG 'RGOING T
NOT GOING  ME YOU  TO A T WON'T
YOUR TESTIMONY AGAINST YOUND
NOW Y D HA
NG IMPORTANT, AS
S DID COOPERAT THEONTHEMT DYNAM
ALL HIS TECHWH